let's talk about this first story right
here louder with crowder.com
officially suing youtube steven crowder
initiates legal action against youtube
from crowder's website they report last
week louder with crowder llc through its
lawyer gave a legal notice to youtube
of the intent to file a lawsuit and seek
an injunction
they go and mention they have a video
available on their website last fall
after the vox adpocalypse youtube
re-monetized crowder's channel
they said we had a record-breaking
election live stream in november
and incredibly successful streams
thereafter if there ever was a target
painted on our backs it was then
once we hit the new year and a new
president ascended the landscape of
social media shifted in favor of the
left
democrats took control the presidency
and now have control of both house
houses of congress as such youtube and
other big tech platforms feel emboldened
with very few lawmakers standing in the
way he says
in 2021 youtube hit them with a warning
of a strike over election content
then issued the first heart strike the
first strike was related to a coveted
policy in their march 18th video
of the one-year anniversary of 15 days
to flatten the curve
the studio is familiar with youtube's
policies on covet so i'll just give you
the
the gist of it and and i went over this
the first time they gave him a strike
crowder did not break
any rules in this capacity and i got i
got really angry because
i get this email from google when this
is going down like well in advance of
any of the censorship
straight up saying here are the exact
conditions you must meet to
violate this policy and i said that's
easy
they said you can't say two specific
things together which obviously i can't
say
because youtube will take us down if i
do even even if i explain it
that's the way this works their
algorithms don't understand the
difference between
explaining something and it's it's all
the same to them
crowder never said that there was
widespread fraud
crowder never mentioned about you know
anything about
overturning or anything like that they
gave him a strike
which is bunk the next one the second
one is the craziest apparently
they're claiming that crowder and his
team were glorifying the death of mikaya
bryant
for agreeing with the police
that the police officers were justified
in the shooting now of course media
matters says that they were mocking you
know uh
the woman i i don't see that as still
violating the policies which says you
know glorifying or reveling in someone's
death
when you're like hey this is the law if
you break it this is what's going to
happen
i think youtube is reaching as crowder
explains he says the concern they have
is that youtube is actively looking for
violations
in their past videos that aren't
actually violations in order to issue
a third heart strike once they're
allowed to stream to the platform
which would deplatform them from youtube
youtube has a
has a pattern of applying policies and
even stretching those policies beyond
any reasonable reading of the policy in
order to harm channels which take a
contrary view of their opinions
we experienced this we have a we only
ever have ever gotten a warning
but it was our episode with alex jones
and they claimed that
a hyperbolic statement was
glorifying violence or something and
they took the they took the full podcast
down
and i said it was it was a half a second
can i just snip it out they're like no
they were they were looking for any
possible excuse to take our video down
and i think that's pretty obvious to
everybody so he was gonna mention
why you should care no matter what side
of the political political aisle you're
on youtube
isn't encouraging debate it's trying to
squash debate trying to eradicate ideas
from its platform it simply does not
like
one day those ideas are about the
election then they're about covid
now those ideas include applauding an
officer for saving a woman's life when
will enough be enough
well this is really important but i
gotta say to uh to steven and crew
obviously we all care i think the people
who watch this show care about
principle and recognize the kami is
going to have their free speech the
nazi's going to have their free speech
and we're going to be annoyed with them
but we're going to argue and that's the
purpose of free speech we want our
rights protected
and that means people you don't like are
they they get rights too
the problem is the plea the people were
up against i hate to call it left and
right because it really doesn't make
sense economically or or even
in terms of tradition versus
progressivism
it's just zealots who want power whose
ideology is there is no truth but power
and then people who are like let's have
a fair debate a fair argument over this
so they're suing they're filing an
injunction
and i wonder what precedent could be set
there's a lot there's a lot of people
need to understand like when you when we
watch james o'keefe filing these
lawsuits against the new york times and
cnn
a lot of people say you can't do it you
can't do it for this that mysteries i
know it's gonna get thrown out
it you can only do it until you do it if
you keep backing down and saying
there's no point in suing because wha oh
what's gonna happen it's gonna be a
waste of money okay listen
i understand if you don't have the money
to file a lawsuit that's a challenge
but if you just sit there and let these
companies do this
there will never be precedent set so
i'll throw it to you guys otherwise i'm
gonna keep ranting on the
censorship uh you know ian obviously you
you were talking about just before the
show
creating terms of service for minds
because you helped put that together
yeah honestly in addition to
it being up against you know like you
said zealots people that are just like
kind of
kind of crazy about political
correctness and stuff we're also up
against centralization of power and
algorithm machine learning algorithms
that aren't necessarily and we're seeing
the flaws in the system of a centralized
service
that's dictating what can and can't be
said through a machine algorithm because
stuff gets taken out of context like you
said you can't explain certain things
even though you're not using it
derogatorily because the the the voice
to text thing they do for captions would
just show the sentence
it doesn't understand i'm like here's
exactly what youtube said i can't say
they'd be like
we see it in the code gone yeah you see
this also in like the firearms industry
or the gun world so there's there's
guntubers people who make
youtube videos you could say grand
thumb's a big one warrior poet
is a good one um hitcock45 hickok he's
great he's classic
yeah i love that so but i mean you can
the so the firearms industry actually in
some ways not the industry but the
community because
culture as well uh was something
somewhat saved by the internet because
it allowed people from
rural areas because a lot of more
firearms ownership in rural areas
communicate with one another and then
they started making youtube channels how
so that people could
learn how to do things and it is
ironically controversial in the united
states right now
i don't want to use ironically too heavy
because it's way too hipster
but it's you're right though yeah right
no but it's it's ironically
controversial that a person can have
their page taken down
because they were teaching somebody how
to not hurt themselves
do you remember when google banned the
word gun yes
this was the best thing because uh so
you couldn't search for the word or
or any combination of the three letters
g-u-n yep
so i searched for the anime gundam yep
it wouldn't come up
you couldn't buy japanese action figures
that's how stupid their censorship is
yeah like my personal
my personal instagram is at foxrow
official and my
search page is all gundams
and motorcycles because it's like you
look at my page i've got
guns and motorcycles but my search
history if you look at the search base
it's all gundam it's all and it's all
anime characters why are you searching
for that it's just
defaulting it well i mean i did play
final fantasy vii once
oh there you go yeah right one of the
best
the roommate was good i thought i
enjoyed the remake yeah
but that music anyway google
uh only re like a lot of people were so
we went to the range yesterday we're
filming the vlog and we fired
the barrett uh was it uh m82a1
that's the kind of nomenclature that
people use yeah and uh 50 bmg
and the and and crowder gave uh he sent
me a year ago
a sig m400 and i also got a a sig
uh tread sight and uh it was amazing it
was just really really great and we did
it all we did it all safe i mean
forrest you clearly know how to shoot
we're giving instruction we also had the
the instructor on
on site and a lot of people were just
like i got asked like 10 times are you
sure you can do this
like youtube will delete your vlog won't
and i'm like i went through the rules
they say as long as you're showing the
weapon and shooting it in a range i mean
obviously there are youtubers
who are still producing but i don't know
maybe we'll get the channel demonetized
yeah i mean there's different types of
content you can see people creating
either it's just like
short films people do that with all the
time with usually with airsoft guns but
you get the point
um but they also do how to like how to
disassemble a firearm so you can clean
it so when you're
your channel your video gets demonetized
because you're teaching somebody how to
safely clean their firearm you're
getting dinged with something that says
you're teaching someone how to us
to manufacture assemble right
which is which is which is one of those
things where like
the the the people who are running the
asylum are not the right people
kind of thing yeah it's it's it's
contradictory
when it's it's you're watching people
perform
gun safety and so they punish you for it
yes so one of the things they said is
that
uh you can only show a weapon in
appropriate place like
a gun store or a range you can't just
have one in like an office room or
something i guess they'll give you a
strike sure you could
so uh there's a local range out here and
they have they have
rooms that look just like classrooms
because they do safety trainings yeah
you can't do that no
no they'll be like oh wow that's not you
know it looks too much like this
right we'll take it it looks like a
school it could be yeah and then you're
gonna get in trouble you're gonna get
dangerous censored
and uh and therein lies the big problem
i love how you said it was ironic
because
america is it's a gun country and these
massive services
namely youtube will ban your content and
i
i have to wonder too there's there's
definitely an overlap here obviously
you know crowder is usually he got i
think what is it what does he have the
walther on his yeah
on his desk he's got a walther yeah
uh-huh and uh i wonder
i i cuz i've always been curious about
that i'm like dude's got a gun sitting
on his desk
or he or he's wearing he's got his
holsters and i'm just like i
i'm pretty sure there's some you know
democrat
anti-gun person sitting at youtube hq in
silicon valley with their finger over
the band button just like your stupid
gun
more on gun oh than and then they're
just waiting they're waiting like like
crowder said they're looking for
something to get him for
yeah and i think that's the part where
you establish intent like the ob
it is not really about honest
disagreement it's
look we're looking at intent now but the
bigger question is
and i'm glad crowder is finding legal
legal action this is a good thing
because like i said you've got to sue
and then
make that argument but they can ban
whoever they want whatever they want
right according to most terms i haven't
read the
youtube terms i know twitter says we can
ban you at any time for
any or no reason mm-hmm that's that's
interesting so
it's interesting now that uh we have we
we as
individuals who operate on these
platforms have no legal protections
and it's interesting maybe we shouldn't
maybe it's our own fault that's why i
set up you know timcast.com because i'm
like okay
i mean i'm fairly libertarian if youtube
has got a company they don't owe me
anything and it's their platform
if somebody came into my house and
started you know like throwing food on
the floor i'd be like
get out someone came to my house started
screaming a bunch of nazi stuff i'd be
like dude get out
not not gonna be having that the
difference is
youtube is has has been subsidized by
google they've monopolized
the space there are platforms where you
can upload videos but
youtube is absolutely dominated and now
it's kind of the only place where you
can run a business it's a really really
complicated argument
no other service offers monetization in
the same way that that youtube does
and so what's this or do they uh recoil
is currently
building and we have recoil tv which
functions similar to youtube and we are
building a monetization path it's
expensive to host these videos though
we and we do we actually we have it so
if you are a firearms man if you're a
firearms content creator
get a hold of us because we'll put you
on recoil tv it doesn't cost you
anything oh wow yeah but but
you guys got to fund that run ads or
something or we fund it through
the fact that people like our
publication really but it it can get
really really expensive so
we so in in for instance in the members
only section of our website we have to
pay for that bandwidth and it is a lot
like it it gets up to tens of thousands
of dollars people don't realize this
youtube's free so we broadcast right now
on youtube
you know we get 40k concurrent views
you know on average during the election
we had like 140 or some on one podcast
that means for the for the two to three
megabits up we're sending out we're
sending out
a hundred and forty thousand two times
two megabits
all of that data youtube's paying for
yeah and then they take a small
percentage of super chats they take a
percentage of
you know advertisements so so the issue
is
they're they're funding the cost for all
of these things
should we be entitled to this service
and that's where things get challenging
and
man uh i'm pretty much on the fence but
so long
as i'm on the fence in terms of like
their business
private company but where where i draw
the line is if they've monopolized
public discourse
if they have grown to this to the size
to where they're influencing elections
now i think it's it's a it's a it's a
public service and that's
that's interestingly a more liberal
argument conservatives never used to
have and i'm like
i think that they've they've grown and
taken over the commons
we don't have town hall discourse
anymore people are
coming to this show and hearing
arguments and discussions and commenting
it's take it youtube youtube's
effectively dominated the space
well now they owe they owe public
discourse
in which case i think it's extremely
dangerous if they're going to start
removing people who are setting up
maybe uh who are setting up their
businesses maybe a better way to put it
is
if a private company bought all of the
available business space in
in in downtown yes certain point people
are going to be like okay fine you can
own it but you can't ban
people for selling a product you don't
like like people can pay you rent
you can set up terms for the property
but we need commerce to exist
crowder needs to be able to speak we
need to be able to have reasonable
discourse
and what the problem i see with this is
that massive multinational corporations
if they see youtube get away with this
they can just start to dominate whatever
public space they want whatever area of
the commons they want
and then just say but it's a private
company it's ours now
shut everybody out and then i don't know
what people get violent
well on the forefront of that you're
also looking at what is the intent again
you think about it in the sense of we
can talk about guns we can talk about
anything political even with stephen
crowder
do they not want him to be heard or do
they not trust
him as a as a good faith actor is a good
question right well
i think if you look at the
the left faction tends to be in my
opinion
a there is no truth but power faction
yep they
accuse the right of being that and it's
really insane
that perhaps many of the establishment
republicans for sure
but when we're looking at anti-critical
race theory individuals and their
alignment on the right these are the
people who reject
that that ethos and so quite literally
you have the left
lying and accusing the right of what
it's doing itself which creates a
serious problem
do they think crowder is a bad faith
actor no i think they believe crowder is
truthful and they don't like it right
because they're bad faith
actors they're trying they're anger
they're angry by his success they're
angry about his success
there are a lot of leftists a lot maybe
maybe the majority who are good faith
but they're following the the the bad
faith
piper believing they're you know
following the truth and then they say
the same thing about trump and trump's
die-hard fans
and i'm like okay but that's not the
majority of whatever this faction is
yeah there are a lot of people who are
like begrudgingly voting for trump
you know and then you have a lot of
people left who begrudgingly voted for
biden
so it's interesting but in the end
people like the you know in in the
intellectual dark web disaffected
liberals
moderates have more in common with
conservatives based on moral frameworks
and rejection of critical race theory
and left identitarianism
believing in free speech than the
establishment democrats
and there's a big difference between
voting for trump and voting for biden
you vote for trump because he's a human
molotov cocktail or because you really
like him in his policies
people vote for biden because he's a
feeble old man they think they can
overtake and steal power
or they genuinely like his policies but
i believe that was probably like a tiny
faction
most of the people voted for him because
he's hated trump yeah based on that you
cannot build the government so
yeah what a house divided against itself
yep so i know most people have more in
common than they realize i think that's
occupy wall street showed that when
when people were railing against the
federal reserve and like the monetary
system
kind of putting us all against each
other and to stop that it's so sad when
people get confused and start to go at
each other like this i don't like it
yeah the no truth but power argument is
a great
form of sort of moral cynicism but it
also it's very manipulative it's not a
very
uh well first of all it's very honest
because the people who say it are only
interested in power so at least they're
on it they're consistent in that sense
but
it says rest in power there is no truth
but power
which is how i'm going and i'm going to
use that philosophy to take your power
and give it to me
it's not the statement there no truth
but power is not complete
it's only the first half it's there is
no truth but power
and i deserve it you know it's
interesting because
there's i understand what they're saying
when they say that
that what's the point of having an
argument with you if
if they want to create their own system
their own utopia their own leftists you
know perfect world
there's no point having an argument with
a bunch of people who disagree with them
they just need to take your power away
destroy your system and then build a new
one so for the time being
i don't i don't think the core of their
philosophy is there's no truth but power
it's
in order for me to build my utopia i
must seize all of your power and the
truth be damned
and that's where we're at right now
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday
at 8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat
and we actually will read your comments
on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you